once upon a time all of Britain was
covered in wild wood a hunting ground
for kings an ancient home for many
beasts few places remain where this
landscape can now be found in the new
forests that world still exists
[Music]
it is an old world full of life where
common creatures live side by side with
the last of the medieval monsters the
new forest contains many unique habitats
here there are trees over 600 years old
for some their time is up but death
brings new life beneath this fallen
giant the earth is stirring a male stag
beetle he has spent the last six years
as an underground grub feeding on the
dead wood now his quest begins to find a
mate before the end of his short adult
life whilst beetles use the trees for
food
another creature uses them to build
amongst the conifers there is a kingdom
of Millions
[Music]
southern wood hands
this fortress may host a hundred Queens
all busy producing the next generation
of workers they might seem like an easy
lunch for larger predators but the
battlements are well defended when
threatened the ants fire Jets of formic
acid enough to make a Robin think twice
drama over the ants return to business
with an army to feed the workers are
always on the lookout for dinner nothing
is off the menu
the oldest ants roamed farthest they
know this terrain inside out but this
worker may have overestimated her
abilities
it's a dung beetle this Goliath is far
too powerful for a single ant it escapes
onto the heath where the woodland has
been kept at bay for centuries equine
teeth have shaped this world but the
ponies create something much more
attractive at least for a dung beetle
his path is filled with many obstacles
but at the end of a hard road the beetle
finds a feast
[Music]
we're gorse replaces grassland another
monster stalks the heath the tiger
beetle with excellent eyesight and
massive jaws it will pounce on anything
that moves
fierce though he is nearby there is a
place where even monsters fear to tread
dry Heath merges into saturated bog
these sundews have a deadly secret their
sweet nectar is a lure and a sticky trap
the victim is slowly digested the soil
here is low in nutrients and sundews
need these supplements to survive this
butterfly is too big for a Sun due for
him the bog is just a feeding ground
but the reeds are also battlefields and
every stagnant pond is a dragon's lair a
keeled skimmer ready to duel clashes are
fast paced and frequent
with the Challenger repelled he can mate
without competition there is no
courtship among dragons
the male seizes any female in his domain
[Music]
mating is brief now the female lays her
eggs
[Music]
she flicks them underwater whilst the
male guards her from above the more eggs
she larry's the more chance some will
survive
[Music]
this dragon will be dead by winter
during his brief reign he will mate as
often as possible so that in the years
to come it will be his descendants who
rule the air
back in the woodland the Stags quest is
at an end
he has found a female so has another to
win her they must jest
[Music]
the stack has proved his worth now it is
time to claim his mate this is the stags
last act his genes will be passed on and
in a few days he will die with mating
over the stag does not release his grip
but the female has good reason to break
free she must find a safe spot to lay
her eggs and ensure the future of her
offspring the new forest has been
unchanged for a thousand years ancient
life still clings to an old world this
patchwork of habitats provides a
stronghold for creatures of a bygone age
the Dragons the Goliath the soldiers of
a great army the last of the medieval
monsters
[Music]
you